are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
[Music]
boom
so uh folks we have a special guest here
with us some people call him the
godfather some call him the godfather
uh i call him gets uh it's it's great to
have him on we did a podcast before but
it was zoomed today we have it in flesh
uh was having a chance to speak to him
and his wife in the back uh and uh
learning about the history soccer tricks
but it's not even that man you know you
just said off camera that you lost 86
pounds you look like you belong in
hollywood oh
look at that you're laughing i'm serious
you look like you belong in hall you
should start casting for some movies man
you're too kind with the green eyes the
whole facial you got the whole thing
going on you are so sweet how are you
doing it is so good to be here uh i've
been wanting for this to happen so thank
you for having me yeah i'm glad you guys
have never met in person never mind you
guys did have a little bit of a bromance
on your zoom we did have we won't bring
up the shack thing and who's getting
what but you guys did hit it off which
was great you know the shack thing was a
visual if him and shaq were to that
that's that's where it went well god was
like i'm the man in the relationship
okay buddy he's the buyer he's the
bottom you say that to shaq space buddy
oh my god but uh so so from from
montreal to miami
and you keep going back to montreal and
you're not staying in miami it's a visit
so tell us why
obviously you have an incredible emperor
i mean i'm sorry you have a great leader
in your country
he's a fantastic guy fantastic so why
does he keep bringing you back to
montreal is it by force is there certain
things that we don't know about that
he's threatening you why why
tell us about it no i honestly it's
because of the golden handcuffs of being
a tenured professor
so you know when so for those for your
listeners who may not know tenure is a
wonderful thing right because it allows
you to have the protection to be able to
do the things that i do right imagine if
the university could have fired me for
any tweet or any paper that i published
that they didn't like so tenure in
spirit is a great thing because
otherwise irreverent professors who are
not or part of the orthodoxy would never
feel comfortable to be able to say the
things they want to say
so on that's in that sense tenure is
great how do you reach tenure and just
take its amount of time
hours right so after you've you you get
your first professorship you have a
certain number of years where you have
to build a dossier the dossier consists
of three elements what have you
published so research teaching and
service
the most important part is the research
how many papers have you published how
much they've been cited how influential
have you been as an academic and then it
goes in front of a tenure committee
and they decide either they're going to
fire you you have one year to leave so
you're not going to be granted tenure or
if they grant you tenure you're
permanent forever you could never be
fired unless you decide to quit
so tenure is
so it's great in that sense but on the
other hand it makes you risk aversive
because if you want to leave you're
always in the backdrop thinking i've got
this professorship for life and you know
it takes a while to build your academic
career you have to have a lab you have
to have graduate students yeah
so it kind of weighs you down
uh so that even though in spirit i very
much would like to be making the move to
the united states i just got killed with
horrific taxes which we can talk about
it's been about five six weeks i've been
walking around in a days
unable to understand how the mathematics
of the money that i started with and
what i ended up with how we can go from
a to b
so i'm desperate to leave guys but uh we
have young children so that even makes
me a bit more risk aversive if our
children were grown already
it'd be a lot easier to say screw tenure
i'm moving to
to miami
and if you if you would you would leave
most likely to a south florida type of
location oh 100 i mean historically i
would have been a socal guy i lived in
i was a professor at university of
california irvine for a few years i have
a lot of family there every summer we go
back to newport beach this in a week
we'll be going back to newport beach but
then the taxes and the wokeness
in california is not that much better
than where i am now in quebec and so
texas of course and southern cal and
southern florida have sort of become
there's like i don't know like in in
miami we have little havana where all
the cubans hang out right i don't know
if it's official but here in hollywood
florida i want to call it like little
quebec is that true oh my god all the
french canadians are down here in the
winter you don't know that yeah i mean i
know that there are a lot of wreckers
down here i didn't know it wasn't that
specific specifically right there's snow
birds right there oh yeah every six
months guy comes up to me at church he
says you know canadians own five hundred
thousand properties in florida yeah what
is that right so he says canadians on
because he's from county says
500 000 properties in florida i believe
it by the way the when he's talking
about tenure you know what the first
thing that comes to my mind you've been
very
vocal about 20 of the bottom half of
teachers 20 of teachers on the bottom 30
30 need to be fired absolutely how do
you grapple that with tinkers all
teachers have tenure of support but what
he's saying is very interesting because
a guy with his views
in a woke environment should get fired
oh i wouldn't have lasted five well this
is when tenure backfires on them on the
walk but but here's my question for you
how did did jordan peterson get fired
and wasn't he tenure as well he didn't
get fired so with george what happened
with jordan is that when the gender
pronoun stuff happened he actually
reached out to me before he became
jordan peterson of great fame and he he
knew of my show
and he knew that i was very irreverent i
wasn't an orthodox car so he reached out
to me he said look you know i don't
think many people are going to be
willing to be talking to me especially
in academia can i come on your show and
that's how we became friends
how many years ago was that this was
2016 maybe or this isn't crazy long ago
no six years ago and you're in mcgill
and he's in toronto i studied at mcgill
for a bit then i went to cornell but i'm
at concordia
there are four universities in montreal
two french two english i'm one of the
two english ones and he was where he was
at university of toronto toronto he
didn't get fired he
he retired
and i think he retired i mean i don't
want to speak for him but i mean i we're
very good friends i know him well uh i
think it became untenable for him to
stay in academia especially given the
amount of other things he's got on
and in a sense i face a bit of a similar
dilemma notwithstanding the tenure you
know i could turn on my uh laptop and
reach a hundred thousand people or i
could sit in a classroom for 13 weeks
and reach 30 kids and i don't mean to
denigrate it's teaching is very
important i love it and it's part of my
dna
but at one point when you've got the
opportunities that someone like jordan
or myself have
it becomes that much more painful to go
through the grind of the daily life of a
professor
so the research is still wonderful i
still love the idea of doing scientific
research and so on but the
administration how slow things move you
know we will hold a meeting to decide on
setting up a task force to have a
committee to decide on whether we're
going to have coffee in the faculty
lounge so we've just spent six months
and probably five hundred thousand
dollars of professor salary to decide i
mean literally on whether we're going to
have coffee the coffee task force the
coffee task force that sounds
interesting very important yeah very
important so it passes not like coffee
in his offices so we had to set up a
task force here just to implement coffee
true story so it's very slow it's uh so
for someone like me very entrepreneurial
very fast moving uh it becomes a bit of
a grind do you sit there yourself and
and
uh
say you know if i stay here and as a
10-year professor i'm going to make xyz
money but if i go
run my own thing and light it up i can
make this much money why what am i doing
why am i putting myself through this i
do think that all the time and i mean so
to speak to what we mentioned earlier
you know i have two two main sources of
income i've got my professor's salary
and then everything else and the
everything else this past year
completely dwarfed my so for example the
book royalties came in for the parasitic
mind and you know all that other money
is not taxed at the source so it goes
into my bank account and then at the end
of the year you have to write those
checks and uh i mentioned this recently
on joe rogan's podcast uh
my wife calls me over on may 2nd
she says give me the password to your
bank account i go into my we go into my
bank account there are two boxes the
quebec and canadian governments are
already in my bank account i enter two
large numbers that correspond to the
taxes that i'm that i owe
and
i press send
and all the money wait six years wait
wait wait wait did you just say when you
go into your bank account yes the
government's already in the bank account
to say how much of that is theirs yes
what do you mean so so your money's in a
private bank or a nationalized bank it
no it's it's a private bank and they
still have their hands on the private
bank to get in there and tell you this
portion is ours they're just making it
easy for me to settle what a sweetheart
of a country so i mean just nice about
it right look at that level of nobility
exactly yeah you know if it were a
nigerian prince scam right and you lost
a thousand dollars or five thousand
dollars you'd be pissed now imagine if i
it's my words right the book my words my
thoughts my lived experience in lebanon
my
30 years fighting work ideas in academia
but they own 50 something percent of
those book royalties so it's a type of
existential rape that's very very
difficult to stand so i've been
literally walking around spewing in
venom like is this the first year where
you're paying taxes like let's real real
money taxes
in the past you know i'm making you know
so it's thirty thousand i'm getting
fifty thousand but this year because the
book royalties came in right right on a
very successful book
plus the speaking engagements trust
everything so that final amount that i
have to settle it's it's literally what
people would have as a savings in
tennessee yeah and it just disappeared
so we went from having money for
retirement having money to buy a condo
in florida to magically gone so how do
you how do you process that how do you
uh uh in that moment when you're doing
it
it does it piss you off enough where you
want to do something about it or is it
kind of like you know what it's just
something we got to deal with oh much
more the former okay i want to hear
about it
look honestly i would i i wrote this on
twitter i said going through the
lebanese civil war might have been
easier than what happened on may 2nd and
i'm being a bit hyperbolic but not much
i mean and we could talk about it if you
want you know i went through the life
you felt financially raped but in the in
the in the most intimate of ways right
because let's suppose i'm a hedge fund
guy
yes everybody works hard for their money
but it's funny money right i got a bonus
a million dollars because i did crypto i
did this this is me sitting down
striking the keyboard
telling my story right i'm selling my
personhood
and then the governments with their you
know they have a cigar and they're
smoking cognac somewhere and they say
hey uh lebanese jew boy
58
is ours right i mean hey you could we'll
allow you to keep your name on your book
but come on the book royalties are ours
you know for the good of the collective
it's almost like when you sat down to
write the book they were sitting right
next to you typing with you
absolutely jesus it you know so it's
it's it's just um plus all the money
that i made extra came from me hustling
right i have to fly somewhere to give a
talk
it's not passive money right it's it's
me saying what else can i do to make
more money to advance my family and then
the government says
58 come on by the way that means a 20
000 speaking gig is really only eight
grand exactly right
twenty thousand dollar speaking gig is
eight grand
um and that doesn't include if you have
to cover the flight food all the other
stuff that's a uh
so so i remember one time i'm in l.a i'm
eating in northridge uh mall we used to
go to this one place we'd have lunch on
sundays after church and
one of the girls whose face was always
on those uh what do you call the bus
bus stop she was always there on the
realtor phone number everybody knew her
for a decade that's who she was
one day we're at the restaurant and say
hey we don't see your face anymore says
yeah i made a decision what's that
you know um we were i was making good
money she's making 3 400 000 income and
then i started realizing that half of
it's going to taxes
and my husband i just made a decision
it's not worth me
working for this much money i'd much
rather stay home so i just stopped in
real estate i stayed home it's not worth
me doing the work to get half the taxes
i said you're being serious says yeah
absolutely we decided to live a smaller
life
so taxes made this family that they're
not trying to change they're not trying
to go be the greatest realtor they're
just trying to be a good citizen they
just made a decision and said yeah it's
just it's just not worth it it's not
worth me working at that level you're
saying it de uh disincentivizes success
greatness achievement all that good
stuff you just say you know what i'll
just be a house well if you think about
in every situation you're in
like even for you to right now you you
know the conversation when you talk
about should i get married should i not
get married in the mind you're going
through you're a high ticket item you
have choices right now right but should
you get married what are you thinking
about what's the incentive for you this
is not a selfish thing this is how we're
wired right what's the incentive for me
to go
bust my ass to so much when i know 58 is
going to take that away from me so the
motivation to create at the highest
level goes away versus in a different
situation incentives more let me add to
this patrick
this is just my income now in quebec
we also have sales tax we have both
sales tax and federal tax so whatever 40
that i'm that the government allows me
to keep
if i spend anything they tax me 15 on
that
and then property tax then school tasks
then carbon tax then gas task at the end
of the year i'm left with roughly 30
now let's think about this in one way
okay
guys i want you to hear this one more
time say that one more time for people
that maybe weren't fully paying
attention on the podcast say that one
more time very important what he just
said go ahead so if we just do my income
tax i'm down to about 40 of what i made
but then whatever is left if i spend
money i'm taxed 15 on that because we
get double tax both provincial sales tax
and federal sales tax
but then that doesn't stop there then
there is property tax there is school
tax carbon tax gas tax so by the end of
the year i'm i'm left with about 30 now
let's put it another way
if you start working january 1st and you
were a pure slave let's go back to
slavery a couple hundred years ago from
january 1st to december 31st you work
for free right for your owner right so
let's now contextualize that metric in
quebec and canada i work for free from
january 1st till september
in september my overlord
justin trudeau and his friends say you
are now allowed to keep some of your
money so it's it's a level of
existential rape that's difficult to
copyright now here's the thing i was
thinking i was telling my wife you know
what maybe my next book
will be to write about what just
happened to me so that maybe it can
awaken people and then i thought it
could never awaken people because 95 of
canadians and quebecers benefit from
that parasitic ponzi scheme right by the
way 40 of canadians from what i read
don't pay a single dollar of tax so i am
the guy that keeps
i and others like me are the ones that
keep the system going right even when i
tweet something on on twitter so that i
can complain about what a lot of people
will will agree with me and say my god
it's unbelievable what's happening to
you but others will take the position of
stop whining you rich pig i mean you
know why don't you share your wealth
with with the rest of us who need it
right so there's a sense of envy and
entitlement whereby if i were to try to
complain about this most people would
not be on board with me because they
benefit from that system can i ask you
the the that's that he just put up the
top 10 percent of earners bore
responsibility for over 71 percent of
all income taxes paid in top 25 percent
paid 87 percent of all the income
and i'm sure you'll find the one that
says 40 percent of canadians don't pay
the nutrition is the top okay there's
another stat that shows that 40 of
canadians don't pay any taxes just do a
search on that
my question was because pat asked the
question the beginning of this
conversation was this the first year
you've made this what you call it like
additional income you you're in your mid
50s give or take yeah exactly okay and
you've been a professor for more than
three decades i've made yes uh 28 years
20 years i've made extra income in the
past but it's it falls within the
digestible right if you're making 80 000
extra and the government takes 30 40 000
you're like okay they're raping me a bit
more but this year was the bonanza year
this is the year where all of my hard
work has finally paid off and the
government said oh no no no it's all
ours so my question is it took you 57
years to have this level of disgust for
taxes
well that's not sarcastic from it but
you've been you've been a professor for
almost 30 years and it took you 57 years
to be like oh i'm going to throw up in
my mouth
but there's a reason for that right
because
when it's built into your salary
it's it's like funny money right you
just accept it psychologically it comes
out of your paycheck it comes out of
your paycheck it's invisible but when it
is that whole big chunk that comes in
that's not taxed at the source and then
you
will write that amount press send and
all of your savings disappear right it's
psychologically it's
of course w2 versus 10.99 yeah 1099. but
you know so i'm sitting with dennis
prager and his wife sue
and we're at their house and i'm saying
so dennis
at what point will you leave california
okay
and he says yeah it's not at a point
right now i said you you complain about
california but you ain't leaving right
if you don't like it why don't you leave
so you know he's like well it's at what
point give me a number what tax rate
does it need to go to for you to
consider leaving he finally says yeah
probably around 70
okay
is there a number that if it got to that
you would sit there and because if
you're saying
15 state federal tax
carbon
property
eventually your half a million dollar
income your million dollar income you're
really only living off 300 dollar income
exactly say your ten year professor's
salary i don't know what the number is
say 150 to 200 i'm just giving a number
out there so if you're making 150 to 200
you're making another 800 outside of
being a professor
if you only took your 800 and you came
to the state of florida and i'm not
trying to recruit for governor desantis
but if you took the 800 and you dropped
your tenure you came to south florida
your wife's probably listened to this so
you're 800 000 you would save an
additional
say 25 points that's 25 points i see
what happens so that makes up for that
but then you would take that time that
you're putting as a teacher you would
make that up in different places by
having more exposure so is it getting to
the point where you're maybe a little
bit con considering doing something it
is okay i appreciate your intimate
questions uh and i don't mind sharing uh
details of our lives it's okay uh maybe
my university will will hear this and
maybe give me a higher salary i don't
think so
they literally have probably a a whole
floor called the godzad problem
reserved just for me uh i think we're
there pat and uh i actually already
started speaking to a uh uh lawyer who
specializes in immigration i don't know
if you guys do you guys know this
there's a visa track called the
extraordinary visa do you know what that
is
it's a it's a very very small number of
people who qualify for it it's you know
you have to be a well-known professor or
you're a grammy award winning singer or
you're an olympian or right and so if
you meet certain criteria and you
demonstrate that you meet them obviously
and apparently i do
uh they kind of expedite your uh
something equivalent to a green card
and so we're now looking at doing that
so that we can have legal because if
otherwise if i don't do that visa any
visa would require for me to be linked
to an employer i'd have to get a
professorship here or you know patrick
would have to give me a one million
dollar a year salary to be your so he's
slowly massaging that conversation let's
get it written now get it going lawyers
getting so so it would have to be so so
but this visa
i can get into the country without any
employer just on the merits of my
dossier and so we have started that
process
got it makes you think you know at what
point is the the pressure
you know at a place where you're willing
to make the move rather than staying
there when i asked jordan peterson i
said jordan i said why are you staying
in toronto so he says you know i'm still
staying in toronto because of different
reasons i said are you staying in
toronto because one day you want to run
for prime minister no i have no desire
why don't you want to run if you think
you can well no i think i can do
more of an impact doing what i'm doing
versus being a prime minister i said i
don't know about that i said listen
philosophers great we'll stick around
but
you know i think prime minister
presidents those guys are going to be
you know somebody that's going to be
remembered do you think jordan wouldn't
make a good pm in canada if you chose to
want to do that i think he's too honest
i i've been also asked to run for high
office and so i'll speak for me but i
think it applies to to your question
about jordan i think
all of the qualities that a politician
needs to have duplicity uh scamming
cheat
uh machiavellianism i don't think jordan
and i scored very highly on those so i
think we would be chewed up in five
seconds again i don't want to speak for
him but
for me
i don't think i could function in that
ecosystem and so i think i agree with
with jordan that our voices are probably
uh more influential doing what we do
here because the political system will
simply squash you into you know saying
what they want you to say and i don't
think jordan or myself are willing to
play that so in other words we have to
put up with what's being given to us in
regards to politicians that's what we
have to deal with so so maybe we need to
stop complaining about corrupt
politicians because we
the good people don't want to run is
that the right solution
as you remember you might remember plato
talked about philosopher kings right
that democracy was too important to be
given to the common person you needed
the philosophers to run things and so
that's i think what you're talking about
it should be someone like jordan
peterson who's running the country but
regrettably in today's world people like
jordan peterson
are too honest to succeed in such a
parasitic world and by the way i
remember that conversation right here a
few months ago you
you you asked that question multiple
times so have you considered and then
you revisited it you know why though you
know why i'm asking that question
because
if if you if if the people
that the people wouldn't mind running
don't run
then you lose the right to complain
about the corrupt people who do yeah so
you don't have the right to complain
about it
because
i don't know if you understand what i'm
saying so so we're sitting there so okay
look at these guys they're saying
something about it yeah no it's it's
either
run
and create some real change and policies
or
don't run and stop complaining about the
people that are corrupt and just say
justin's a great guy
okay and he's the best guy that we got
today but you to me i may be wrong you
can't do both but see you you can't sit
there now listen i'll give you uh flip
side of it as well
the other side of it for me would be to
follow one here's the flip side of it
if jordan peterson or i'm just in this
situation we're just using jordan but
pick anybody you know whoever that uh
has that kind of influence right
if a jordan peterson-esque type of an
individual said no i'm not running no
problem why don't you create an academy
and go
work with the current 25 year olds
and prepare them for the next year 10
years
so they can run for office and teach
them all the machiavellian stuff that
they're going to go through
have them read prints have them read 40
laws of power have them read
all the stuff that's going to happen and
give them strategies challenge them push
them put them against each other pin
them against each other give them a
topic to play for it against it argue
against it something they believe in but
argue how the other person would argue
against it and then try to find the
leaks and here's liz and look at this
article look how this person handled
this debate then shape their mindsets 10
years from now
so then in 10 years you got a roster of
20 people that can run but to me it's
one of the two didn't you say obama did
something like that you remember about
speaking of ritz crawford exactly 2 000
african american kids in their early 20s
good looking men like i'm talking and
the way they spoke i'm like you sound
like you could run you said they were
sharp everybody was sharp so i go into
sneak peek i'm like oh my god
fire imagine two thousand barack obamas
and michelle in the room
and i said what's going on here so well
this is uh michelle and brock are gonna
be here this is an organization that's
helping uh develop the next
african-american leaders that may one
day become
uh uh leaders of the free world and
presidents but they were lawyers there's
a lot of lawyers in that room so you
know what i said i said good for you
that's what you're supposed to do okay
so there's not a you know this whole
concept with the academy the book that
i'm you know publishing right now that
we're going through
um
we though the people like that can do
such a great job in because there is one
thing to do videos and we're glued to
the screen and somebody watches oh my
god god you oh wow what a great argument
okay so this is the satire approach if
you want to go this angle great oh my
god look at this jordan peterson crate
but then there is
all right come into the room close the
door get rid of all the cameras leave
your phones outside let's talk
here's how you handle this
there's difference between that and that
group
what you're talking about used to be
called universities right i mean right i
mean the way we train people in critical
thinking and in debate skills and in
evidence-based decision-making we used
to be called the university and in a
sense that's what i've been railing
against for the past you know almost 30
years we had these institutions right
and you know
when i first started my career
i'm not sure if we discussed this when i
first came on your show remotely
so what i do is i apply evolutionary
biology and evolution psychology to
study human behavior right
well when i saw how social scientists
would respond to my work where they
didn't like the fact that i'm applying
biology right biology was great to
explain the behavior of the mosquito and
the zebra and the dog but what do you
mean you're applying biology to explain
consumer behavior what are you some kind
of nazi and so that's when i first was
exposed to this idea that even very
educated people my fellow professors
could be parasitized by stupidity and so
that really was the genesis of how i
eventually wrote the parasitic mind
because originally it started in my
scientific career where i would see
these incredibly brilliant people
who would completely lose it at what i
thought was a terribly banal point which
is of course humans are driven by their
hormones by their physiology i mean who
doesn't think that that's feasible but
yet in the social sciences we have
erected these edifices of of
of knowledge for the past hundred years
completely devoid of any biology so you
could study anthropology sociology
economics you could be in the business
school where i'm housed and the word
biology is never mentioned once but how
could you study things like economic
decision making employee psychology
employer psychology consumer psychology
without ever mentioning biology so
you know
the things that you're hoping for the
academy that you're looking for we used
to be called the university and i'm
hoping that we will return regain the
power of the university because we've
truly lost it
i i
i don't i don't know i don't know if
it's going to go back to that
but i i think what
could happen a lot
is if individual academies are created
yeah
i think if individual academies are
created and by the way that's when uh uh
you you go you'll go and talk to like
let's just say the syrian community i'm
a syrian right we're talking your wife
is armenian i'm armenian so we're
talking armenian and i like how your
wife was translating everything i was
saying she's like this is what he means
he just said this his mother is armenian
his dad's a syrian please go ahead tell
the people how beautiful she is go ahead
no
listen you you're you're a very good
looking guy and i told you that you look
like you're omar sharif type of you know
guy that's got to be in hollywood your
wife's dropped it gorgeous she's
beautiful so good for you
congratulations on you guys by the way
that uh that was your birthday gift
sweetie from last week you just you just
got a huge shout out from patrick david
that's your gift she's beautiful it was
great meeting her no but so so you're
sitting there and you're thinking like
this whole thing with academy right
and you're saying okay what if what if
you know she's a syrian you know armenia
where they're talking i'm talking to
these assyrian folks and they run a
church or they run the club the syrian
community
and we'll go in there and you'll all of
a sudden see like no well you guys are
kids and you don't know what you're
talking about listen why don't you
create an academy
and develop the next leaders that are
coming up
and and teach them history ritual teach
them stuff that work teach them the
50 biggest mistakes assyrians made and
what we can do to learn from it right
hey what are the biggest mistakes a
candidate has made a republican
candidate a democratic candidate
i don't know if that's taking place
where those leaders are being developed
like i asked uh
is not not hillsdale college it is
hillsdale college but you got heritage
foundation you got hillsdale college you
got some of these places that are out
there okay what are you doing to develop
the next guys that are coming up okay
charlie kirk is doing turning point usa
and it's growing fantastic
but i'm more talking about doors closed
you know i've developed leaders but i've
given tens of thousands of speeches in
the last 20 years
take any of those speeches that i've
given
and then
ask who i've built the most it was a lot
of small group setting one on one one on
five one and ten one in 20 where it's
like sitting there going
that's where real development is made so
if you don't want to run for prime
minister no problem why don't we create
an academy where you take the next 50
100 guys that are out there and every
year create a one week camp kind of like
how michael jordan does his one-week
camp kyrie irving's got us all these
basketball players have their own camps
that you go to every summer yeah great
why don't you create a two-week camp
every summer i guarantee you there's
parents out there that would spend the
five thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars for their kids to spend time
with you and maybe there's gonna be an
element of here's five ten thousand
dollars i'm gonna send my kid to be with
you for two weeks
but it's gonna be all day every day and
then if the parents wanna also be there
that's another five thousand dollars for
the parents they said all the way in the
back they're not involved so your kids
are in the front you see the curriculum
so you know how to follow up with your
kids but you're in the back there's a
glass or whatever so you're not getting
involved and messing it up and he's
doing whatever he's doing with the kids
pinning them against each other debate
topic what do you think about this what
do you think about that read this really
really going through this intense
environment
i don't know if that exists today but if
it did exist and it was by people like
this
i think it would blow up and not only
blow up the future leaders would be
built coming out of many of these places
can i give a counter argument do so well
because i'm going to go back to
gadsad's initial argument is why would i
sit down in a classroom
with 30 people when i can go onto a
youtube or a webinar or whatever and get
30 000 people on there so it kind of
comes down to your motivation and how
many eyeballs you want and is the money
the
the the the motivating factor is it is
it change is it creating something the
vision that you want
i'm throwing this to you because you
said at the onset of this conversation
why would i sit down and do a lecture in
a classroom and i could just do it on
youtube for me look
an academic has two it's a two-step
process number one you have to create
knowledge and i do that of course
through writing books through writing
academic papers but then the second part
is disseminating knowledge right
because by the way do you know how what
is the average number of times that an
academic paper is cited in the in the
academic literature can you guess how
much
zero the the the mean number of times
meaning that on average most academic
papers are cited by no one i mean you do
all this work and zero people give a
[ __ ] zero people give a [ __ ] exactly now
not all papers some papers are started
ten thousand times and that person
becomes few and far between i'm just
doing it exactly the average person is
producing garbage and again i'm not
denigrating academia but academics come
in different shades right some are very
very influential most do research that's
only read by their mom and the reviewer
right
and i've mentioned the story many times
before uh
but it's worth repeating so in 2017 i
had been invited to stanford business
school so that's pretty much the mecca
of prestige if you know in academia i
was giving a talk on one of my
scientific papers and the gentleman who
took me out the uh the host is a fellow
professor and the night before we went
out to dinner and so at one point he
asked me says well you know i didn't
know you were such a you know academic
celebrity you hang out with joe rogan
you go on joe rogan i said yeah you know
it's great he said so he says it now
look with the kind of an air of disgust
the hottie here yeah well you know at
stanford we don't condone that i said
you don't condone what exactly he said
well you know we don't do research so
that could be sexy enough
so that we can talk about it on joe
rogan i said well i don't do research i
could appear on joe rogan but surely
it's better to both do great research
and be able to
discuss it on joe rogan because now 20
million people will see it yeah well we
don't we don't do that at stanford so
look at the mindset his mindset was i
only speak to a few of my anointed class
colleagues right i don't speak to the
great unwashed the rubes right whereas
for me an opportunity to come on pat's
show where i can reach millions of
people i'm jumping on that because i
don't have that elitism right i want now
there's kids who are going to be
listening to say i want to be that next
guy so in a sense i agree with both of
your positions we can do it intimately
with 20 people but we could also do it
with 2 million people on pat's show well
can you speak to the mindset of the
professor because i'm going back to this
like coffee task force so i assume it
got implemented and there's coffee at
your college but when you walk into the
break room in the coffee room and
there's you and a dozen other professors
what's the overall sentiment like oh
there's the [ __ ] hot shot
totally what is that vibe so look as you
probably know the seven deadly sins
include envy as one of the sins right we
also know from the ten commandments
don't covet your uh your your professors
your paper exactly and so so envy
regrettably is
it might it drives the economy right
keeping up with the joneses all those
[ __ ] next door have that fancy car i
want that fancy car so envy is driving
me to so what happens to a lot of my
colleagues is what's called an ego
defensive strategy they can't go on
pat's show
because they're not interesting and
charismatic enough but they know how to
write academic papers in a certain model
in a certain template they have mastered
that ability but they would love to go
on joe rogan but they can't pull it off
therefore they'll denigrate those who
can do it right so i'm a sellout right
because if i were really a haughty
professor i would only be publishing in
the top academic paper journals but
here's the thing i do publish in the top
academic journals so they can't hold
that against me so i do both but to them
you're a sellout for coming on pat's
show that's two vulgarits for the masses
what's the phrase the those that can't
do teach yeah right how do you process
that
look i i don't i don't think it's true i
mean i think it's a bit of a
misnomer to say that only those who
can't do teach because
uh
you know if you study criminal behavior
and you're a criminologist should you
have been a corrections officer or a
criminal or so there are certain
scientific principles that you could
apply so i could teach entrepreneurship
even though i may not have been a great
entrepreneur myself so i don't
necessarily buy that but it is true that
academia because of the slowness of how
things move breeds a bit of a parasitic
culture a deadwood culture so many
people regrettably after they get tenure
will stop producing whereas the real
academic is not encumbered by tenure
right i i've i've been more productive
after i got tenure than before i got
tenure right so
my my former doctoral supervisor at
cornell just retired i just came back
from ithaca
but i saw the video you did with the
purple hair do you like that yeah it was
hot but there you are by the way i
received you can't imagine how many
letters from people from ithaca
telling me thank you so much i'm afraid
to open my mouth in ithaca wow and your
ability to satirize it is just
unbelievable
every single store every business every
car had blm
black transgender lives matter how many
black transgender people exist four
right
so i mean so for i mean it's just
unbelievable right but that's the
mindset the woke rabbit hole
nothing is as bad as ithaca which i hate
to say because cornell is where i was
trained i love ithaca you said and i
watched that the that segment that you
did
uh which i'm slightly turned on not
gonna lie um
you said look where's the wokest place
in the world and you kind of set a few
cities is it in berkeley or again is it
in oregon and then you're like nope
right where i went to college over here
in ithaca new york cornell brutal why is
it so bad there
so i
here's one supposition i think it
started off in the 60s as the super
let's all hug you know peace through
reggae music and you know that's that's
not crazy far from woodstock
exactly it's kind of the woodstock vibe
and then because it already has the the
ground for that kind of lovey-dovey
stuff then the walk parasites can come
in and then build on that so it becomes
this kind of beautiful melange of
hippie stuff with wok stuff and
everybody is transgender everybody has
blue blue you know pink hair and so on
it's just it's unbelievable it really is
it almost feels like a caricature like a
satirical piece it's just unreal so
who's thanking you for pointing this out
so i i had a guy who owns a gym right to
me and by the way if they're listening
to this all the people who wrote to me
my apologies if i don't write back i do
read all your messages i always feel so
guilty when people take the time to
write it's busy guys i mean let me give
a little break here but i you know once
a month i will send out a
grand apology to everyone because i
didn't respond but i do read those
messages so i've got all kinds of people
a guy works at a coffee shop he's not
woke but he's afraid to say he's not
work a guy who owns a fitness center in
ithaca
all kinds of people who said to me
you know we watched your clip and you
know i give them kind of a
a
a rope to sanity right because you start
wondering whether because you're not
woke but everybody around you whether
there's something wrong with you and
then here comes the blue a pink or what
is it purple haired professor who's
who's able to have the guts to make fun
of these things and then they suddenly
feel sane again that there's you know
this imprimature of a professor who is
agreeing with them yeah i feel like this
is the perfect segue for the whole bill
maher
uh segment that he did about i i uh you
and i last time when we were speaking i
think we talked about i told you the
story about my friend who we went to
this gay bar in nashville and the guy
says how do you know you're not gay
that's right and the entire drive back
is like how do i know how do you know
how do you know it's like you can't ever
try it's messing with my head and you
have to find out for him so i'm like
dude you don't need to find out
and i got to do my research like a
professor here i got to get that tenure
he had to go figure it out for himself
that he's not and it was like such a
weird thing to go through it's like no
i'm not gay i'm like you honestly you
have to do that to kind of go through
this process
imagine doing that just to fight guys
good news i'm not gay but i you know
yeah me and the buddy down can you
imagine that story right there so i'm
like okay but then i asked you a
question i said so let me ask you do you
think
with all these tv shows like yes last
night we're sitting in the uh at the
house uh uh morals in town and we're
having conversations all this stuff and
hey what movie you watch all this stuff
and
you know we're talking about jurassic
park the one that just came out which
honestly whoever's gonna be offended by
this it is what it is one of the worst
movies i've seen
in the last few years but when all the
dinosaurs are gay and trans what do you
expect it's just horrible okay
and then you watch top gun it's better
than top gun one anyways so then we look
at cartoons for kids so the new cartoon
is a toy story guy what's the guy's name
lightyear what is it
yeah and you know in there there is a
character
where uh there's a lgbt uh characters
that they're kissing each other and
they're holding the baby okay in a
cartoon
and originally
the ceo the company said we're not gonna
do this we're going to cut this because
this is too much
and the employees at disney pixar
came out protesting where they finally
said leave it in there so it's in the
cartoon right
so i'm sitting there and we're having a
conversation whether we're going to
watch this with our kids or not whether
we're going to watch this with our kids
i said there's no benefit for me to
watch this i said if you want to watch
porn whatever kind of kinky pony you
like to i don't know what kind of porn
you watch whatever you watch
give it to yourself you don't need to
put it in a movie for me to watch and
then it's my choice you know i don't
know what his choice for porn is he's
expressed it a few times you know it's
usually men in purple wigs that's my
kind of thing these days i don't know
with a big basketball player in front of
them
but but the point is i said i said it's
a little too much where you're selling
too many things to my kids and i'm out
of it and i asked you i said yeah do you
think
all these shows all these movies are
making us or making kids increase the
population of the lgbtq community and
you said no i don't think it's affecting
it as much as it is
and then bill maher three weeks ago
comes out if you can post that one
picture what bill maher put
he says at this pace within the next 20
years we're all going to be gay is what
he said because the percentages of if
you can zoom that in that's actually
very interesting he says the silent
generation only point eight percent are
gay the baby boomer generation only 2.6
percent gen x
is 4.2 millennials 10.5 gen z
one out of five gen z is part of the
they they see themselves as part of the
lgbt identification it's lgbtq
what's causing it so i can i could maybe
tease it up tease it out a bit tease it
apart a bit uh
to try to be gay in so for example if
i'm a man and i want to be cool and be
part of a fad it's going to be involve
sodomy in dark corners that takes a lot
of behavioral uh commitment on my part
you follow what i'm saying on the other
hand if i just have to self-identify as
trans that's not nearly as much of a
behavioral commitment right so so one
could could be prone to a fad
the latter one whereas the former one
it's very unlikely that i'm just going
to get into anonymous gay sex because
it's fetish to do so
to speak to your point to the point of
your friend who who didn't know if he
was gay or not i know if i'm interested
in turkish guys and gay saunas right so
i don't think that so so there's a paper
by the way by a i think she was a
pediatrician and i i mentioned her in uh
the parasitic mind her name was lisa
littman
do you know her do you know her story so
she wrote a paper in plus one which is
an academic journal where she was
exactly arguing in much more scientific
terms what bill maher is arguing there
that the
trans uh move or phenomenon is really
one of a social contagion
right now that makes sense right because
if i'm a young kid who you know is
feeling a bit uh
ostracized i can get a lot of ego
strokes by belonging to a group today
that feels fadish that doesn't require
much behavioral
investment and on my part to simply say
you know i may be self-identifying as a
girl or a boy whatever it might be i
think it's a lot harder to be fattish
about your sexual behavior right and
especially if you're a man so for
example we do know from research that
women are a lot more sexually fluid in
other words it makes a lot more sense to
for a woman to say you know in college i
dabbled
whereas it's a lot harder for pat and i
to say you know in college when we were
watching an nfl game then we started
wrestling with each other and then and
then sodomy broke out so so when it
comes to to men i think there's a lot
less fluidity i really know if i'm gay
or not for women it's a lot more fluid
and the trans craze for many kids who
identify as trans it's really because
it's just fetish now by the way lisa
lipman
when she published the paper did you
guys put it up uh oh yeah exactly when
she published the paper i right away
reached out to her because at first it
was published and then it caused all
kinds of problems and then they wanted
to retract it so i invited her on my
show because i'm always the guy who
invites all these folks who are
otherwise getting brutalized by
everybody else and no academic is
courageous enough to invite them and she
wrote back to me saying look i would
love to thank you so much for the offer
but she was scared at the time
because she thought she just wanted it
to die
you know the story to die away but i i
think it's never a good idea to do that
because the once the you know the blue
haired taliban comes after you they're
going to come after you no matter what
so if you try to placate them if you try
to apologize it's never going to work
quick story about not apologizing
and actually you just met my wife so
this is a story about my wife so we had
got your hot wife my hot wife thank you
we had gone to a cafe a local cafe that
we always go to in montreal and my wife
had just met this new barista who looked
as though
they were transgender so she came back
to me and said you know you know god i
felt very uncomfortable because i don't
want to say something that would offend
that person i didn't know how to address
them and so i wrote out a tweet where i
said uh you know she was frozen in fear
not sure about what to say because you
don't want to hurt the person's feelings
that tweet was meant to demonstrate how
empathetic and kind she was that she was
so
unsure of how to handle them
26 million tweet impressions later and
two three days of millions of mob coming
after me including valerie bertinelli
you know the the former child actress
who basically said my wife is mentally
they completely misconstrued the tweet
the tweet was about my wife didn't want
to say something that would hurt that
person's feeling she was being
empathetic she was being the person
because she didn't want to call them by
the wrong pronoun by the wrong pronoun
okay uh so i could have easily taken
down the tweet i could have apologized
what did i do being the king of all
honey badgers i then satirized their
[ __ ] i did you guys know the series
that i do under under the table where
i'm under the yeah under the desk yeah
so this is this is where i mock the idea
that you know i'm always afraid right
donald trump has just become president
i'm hiding uh you know brett kavanaugh
just became justice i'm hiding
so i hate i hid under the table and i
said that unlike
the isis folks that i had to run from in
lebanon in the mid 70s
the pronoun taliban are incredibly
scarier than the guys that i ran away
from in lebanon so what i did is i
mocked their hysteria i waited out i
didn't apologize for anything and guess
what they got bored and went away so
life lesson guys unless you really have
something to apologize for
never apologize wow
can we stay right here on this topic
because this fascinates me and i know
that you have had some strong feelings
about this but you use the word social
contagion you use that the word last
time
with pat on the zoom interview and you
said and i looked up the definition it
says it's the behavior and emotion
spread spontaneously
through a group or group think and then
you also use the the terminology which i
had heard before courtesy of eminem
which was the terminology called munch
housing syndrome yes right
which um he basically said he was a do
you remember when he talked about his
you know why he hates his mom so much
for all of our hip-hop fans out there oh
she used to do this doubts his whole
thing he's like why he hate i'm sorry
mama i never meant to hurt you yeah i
don't know that he was a victim of
months hundred syndrome that whole thing
tyler you might know this you're a rap
guy
and that's where you deliberately used
to know the line by heart there you go
buddy uh and so you deliberately produce
symptoms of illness so that people care
for them so you're the center of
attention yeah are you saying that's
kind of what's going on with the lgbtq
is you want to it's almost like don't do
as i do do as i say like i'm identifying
as lbc uh lgbtq or whatever it is or
trans but i'm not really
doing it behind closed doors so let me
let me let me yeah let me build on that
so thank you for that question uh in
2010
i wrote a paper which i published in the
medical journal
uh it was on munch hausen syndrome by
proxy and so let me let me describe and
you could probably pull out that paper
munch house and syndrome is exactly what
you said adam this is when i feign a
medical illness in order to garner
empathy and sympathy that's munchausen
syndrome munch housing syndrome by proxy
is even more diabolical this is when i
take someone who's under my care
my biological child my pet my elderly
parent and i harm them so that i can
garner the empathy and sympathy by proxy
so by harming the kid then everybody
comes to me oh poor you poor parent you
have this child so the a lot of the
transgender craze from the parental
perspective is a form of much housing by
proxy right look at me i have a child
who has you know gender identity issues
so it's but in that sense by proxy it's
that paper that i published in 2010
that then led me in the parasitic mind
to
diagnose the victimology currency that
we see today in society as a form of
collective munchausen and collective
munchausen by proxy the idea being
that it is no longer
the mechanism by which we ascend the
hierarchy through meritocracy right i am
the most accomplished professor
therefore i should get the big reward
now it's am i a bigger victim than both
of you right and if i am then i win
right so feel bad for me feel bad for
you you should feel the baddest for me
exactly so so now so i warned now nearly
two decades ago i've been warning people
that once these type of parasitic ideas
take hold in the universities it's the
end of science now i don't mean to be
the guy sitting telling you i told you
so but i told you so so and let me
explain how it manifests itself in
academia
you could no longer now apply for a
scientific grant without submitting as
part of your grant what's called the
diversity inclusion and equity statement
which i call in the book die because
that's the acronym right
diversity inclusion equity is where
meritocracy goes to die literally why
because now we no longer adjudicate
whether we're going to give you three
hundred thousand dollars to do your
research based on the merit of your
scientific research
is your die statement woke enough now
what is the die statement uh are you
going to be hiring uh transgender people
of color
is your methodology going to incorporate
indigenous ways of knowing it it it if
it defies even gatsas satire and
caricatures right what does it mean to
do indigenous way of knowing there is no
indigenous way of knowing there's only
the scientific method right there is no
lebanese jewish way of doing
evolutionary psychology there's just
evolutionary psychology there is no
is it a syrian or syrian assyrian yes
there is no assyrian mathematics there
is just mathematics that's what makes
the scientific methods such a
democratic
epistemology it allows us to keep our
personal identities at the door right
you just do math you just do chemistry
you just do psychology but now we're
reverting back to the epistemological
dark ages whereby whether i get a grant
or not is literally encoded in terms of
how woke i am i have a colleague of mine
at mcgill he's a physical chemist he's
been denied two grants he's a very
serious scientist
he actually came to dinner when jordan
peterson came to montreal two weeks ago
uh he also came to dinner with us this
gentleman his name is pat
he was denied two grants as a physical
chemist
by the way he's a brown person i mean
much browner than we are i mean he's
from he's from india okay so he he
checks the box of person of color
he's been denied
because he won't play the walk game so
imagine how outrageous it is that in the
21st century whether we give scientific
grants to people is not based on the
scientific merit of their grants but
based on how woke they are it's it's
grotesque it's unbelievable can i ask
one follow-up question with this because
i got to tell you this might be
i might get canceled for bringing this
up right now but i'm going to bring it
up anyway because i'm not scared pat but
as you're saying this social contagion
and munch houses syndrome
and how basically you want people to
feel bad for you because you want more
attention you want more attention
the name that comes to mind for me
speaking of trans of who's the face of
trans these days
caitlyn jenner caitlyn jenner bruce
jenner yeah so i have a theory you tell
me if i'm crazy if i'm wrong if i've got
it all wrong feel free as pat says tear
me a new one whatever tear down my
argument i've been around bruce jenner
all right people that that follow the
podcast field i used to be friends with
chris humphries and kim kardashian i
used to be in that kind of world for a
little while and i spent a lot of time
around bruce jenner this was when he was
bruce jenner
and all he talked about
was the 1972 olympics was it 72 or 76 76
montreal okay that's all he talked about
gad okay keep this is 2011 all right and
you know we're getting ready for the
wedding i'm a groomsman in the wedding
right like my boy's about to marry kim
kardashian and he's like come here adam
and he's helping me like fix my ties
like let me tell you when i was in the
76 olympics and what we did i was like
this guy really talking about the seven
like this is what his story was and my
theory is this he's surrounded by women
right kim chloe kendall this one that
one all right chris all the k girls
and he's the one guy right
and well there's the brother but he kind
of was like shunned um and they're
getting all this attention and eyeballs
and eyeballs and eyeballs and if you
fast you know rewind he was the
decathlon winner was the biggest name in
the world at one point and now he's like
an afterthought in this
feminine world
and at some point he said you know what
i've been a man's man for 50-something
years
now i'm caitlin
now all the eyeballs are on me diane
soares interviewing him he's he's what
was he woman of the year he was women in
like 2016 whatever it was
so all these eyeballs around him look at
me look at me look at me so am i crazy
for identifying this as sort of some
sort of uh what do you call it social
contagion munch houses syndrome am i
completely out of here
so i don't know enough about his his
personal story to be able to confirm if
it's not i mean
you certainly have a set of causal links
that might make sense uh but it seems to
me that it would be it would require a
big behavioral commitment for him to
engage in all that he's engaging simply
because he wants that kind of attention
i mean did you get a sense that he was
starving for attention when you would
interact with him again his only claim
to fame
via
you know up until 2016 was that he won
the olympics in 1976.
so
anytime like imagine if you're citing
all your soccer stories from the 1980s
right it's like at some point it's like
god we get it you played soccer but
what's up now yeah yeah it's like if pat
only talked about being a bodybuilder
and he had nothing else to offer yeah so
at some point you're like you know what
this might get some eyeballs anyway
that's my have you heard him speak have
you heard him in interviews have you
heard him give his point of view in
perspective have you actually seen him
why are you calling him him
no no
i i met him i met him yes when 2003 it
was tom hopkins seminar yeah i mean we
have a picture together but when you see
him speak do you see him as a person
that is
have you seen how he answers questions
how he processes issues then or now
today
uh yeah i've seen him a little bit yeah
i mean he's very
you know he's kind of like woke but on
the right
republican but lgbt it's kind of
confusing yeah he doesn't come across to
me as an airhead
uh he comes across as a very uh the way
he gives us answers and processes issues
and
he doesn't come from an angle of feel
sorry for me or sympathy it's a very
interesting uh uh
you know situation with him when you
when you hear him speak but it's also
kind of confusing but but it is but but
so there's a part of what you're saying
maybe makes sense because it's very very
hard for you to
walk into a room and get all the
attention
and all of a sudden you walk into a room
you're not even the top seven of getting
all the attention right that can really
ma
and i'm talking about in your own family
yes so it's okay if you go out there
and you're getting all the attention and
then all of a sudden you go to a
different environment and another person
is getting all the intention but it's
not your family
then you go from in your family you're
the guy that gets all the attention then
all of a sudden it's your wife then it's
one of your dancers they're like all of
a sudden you disappeared hey guys i'm
also important here too that could
happen for you you bring up an amazing
point you go from number one in your
family and there was no doubt in there
zero doubt yeah he was number one and
then boom boom boom boom boom daughter
famous daughter famous white famous
daughter famous younger daughter younger
daughter and now you walk into a room or
you go into a red carpet and they're
like hey would you step out of the way
we're trying to take pictures of all the
ladies and he's standing in the corner
and at some point he said you know what
[ __ ] it i gotta become a lady
i might be crazy here but there's some
element of him like this is gonna be
this is gonna sound strange for me to
bring this up but i mean whoever
interviews
him to have this conversation if he's
it's a personal question but
you know do you think he's had
any kind of a
sexual experience with a man since he's
had the sex change see
i i and let me explain to you why i'm
going in this in this direction like
this is not i'm not being silly i'm not
being i'm not at all trying to be funny
or sarcastic at all
because
if he has
then it's a desire if he hasn't the
motive was a different motive yeah it
was just to get the attention you know
what i'm saying right like i could be
wrong but i still think he likes women
yeah i think he's just identifying as a
woman now yeah
yeah i could be wrong
yeah so i don't see him hanging out with
dudes and it but but again
go go back to
the power of
the power of peer pressure
the the power of peer pressure being
around you the power of you know the
eyeballs the the power of what fame does
to you
the power of some people don't know how
to handle fame early
you know the power of when it's taken
away
taken away being an afterthought yeah
but like like you know like okay so you
know how think about how much it sucks
to be
michael jordan's son
okay yeah think about that like one time
i'm having a couple what's his name
again
exactly exactly so one time i'm having a
conversation with one of my guys and i
said you know what's more annoying than
a bad example he says what's that i said
a great example he says what do you mean
i said okay so kid who had a let's just
say a bad example as a father let's just
say
you know that kid's got a point to prove
to outdo the father so then he does and
he becomes a better man than his father
but it didn't take a lot to earn that uh
what do you call it that uh
stature you know i'm more successful
than my dad okay so now you got what you
wanted you've done better you're better
man than your dad is now flipping and
put your dad is
a person that is very powerful and you
have to outdo that person okay but now
go be that father
and that father who is on top of the
world
and everybody thinks nobody's gonna out
to you and then somebody does
so i think i think in those cases yeah
the best advice that i can give the
child
is to not follow in their parents
footsteps i agree right so for example
your dad is michael jordan become a
neurosurgeon but that's this is not even
the conversation the conversation is
what if you are michael jordan
and your son out too out does you right
that's this situation because he's chris
you know he's you know the guy who's
bruce jenner you know crushes it and
then you're everywhere you go you're
that guy now your kids do bigger than
you they're more famous than you they're
more successful than you they're richer
than you
how does he process that it's a very
different situation that he's going
through speaking about montreal 1976
olympics it would be i would be remiss
if i did not mention the fact that my
brother
was in the same olympic village as bruce
jenner because my brother was an
olympian in the 1976 olympics in judo
did something happen between them
is that kind of where you're going i'd
be remiss
they were in the locker room yeah and
next time hey guys it was just locker
room talk it there's nothing happening
another thing by the way i i think you
guys are mma guys are you right yeah yes
we have them here all the time so before
before the whole thing with mma started
where the idea was can you get guys of
different
fighting traditions to go into the
octagon and fight each other i had had
that conversation probably 15 years
before the mma came came to be with my
brother who was an olympic
judica and i
my brother is is really small of stature
but he's a bulldog right and we would go
to clubs in southern california in the
early late 80s early 90s
and he always walked as though he's six
foot eight right he just has this this
confidence about him you know we'd be
interacting with bouncers and so on and
i would always say to him do do you
think that you would be able to take
this guy and so so to as a preemptive
thing of the mma as a pr
he would say god as long as the guy
doesn't knock me out
as i'm approaching him if i get him
he's finished
and that's exactly what you would see in
the mma now where the guys who can take
you down on the floor are usually the
ones who are khabib's of the world right
so my brother
was already saying that as a judo cup
you know back in the late 70s and early
80s maybe you could put them up anyways
that's it is that michael jordan put up
put up godzilla's brother by the way i
want to apologize to our audience our
young friend tyler over here googled
michael jordan's son and michael b
jordan the world famous actor showed up
that is not that michael jordan's son
i i hope he'll be happy that i'm giving
him this uh that's your brother that's
my david sad david sad
so he used to be a badass that's what
you're saying look look at those look at
this go to this
let's have this is him huh no that's me
that's you that's jesus with the
guys stop the podcast let's just get it
let me know what's going on here right
now are you questioning your sexuality
right
you're throwing some purple hair there
god
holy moly god this is so listen then it
makes sense then it makes sense why you
got a model out there that you call your
wife you know that by the way she she
told me many times how come i never got
the eight-pack
and now i told her she's left i'm only
with this guy now i'm not eight-pack now
but i'm sort of closer to this you're
back baby i'm back baby
did we do we resolve the issue with
bruce jenner but do i have a crazy point
there i i think it's a bit speculative
so i'm not willing to grant you the
professorial imprimatur but i'm not 100
wrong not 100 wrong a bit speculative
though i i said that i got this i could
be crazy for this but yeah that's my
theory and i'm just well let's let's
look at some of the stuff that's going
on right now so jake paul you're
familiar with jake paul i don't think so
what was that so you're like the one guy
in america who isn't at this point you
don't know logan paul or jake paul no
the blonde guys who are boxing everyone
you're being sarcastic i swear to god
i'm not you just said you're a ufc guy
i'm not a ufc oh gotcha i'm not do you
recognize this character okay oh yes i
think i recognize that so jake paul who
is setting up all these fights okay uh
and his brother has said before that he
has aspirations to be a president one
day
jake paul comes out which by the way he
these guys have never talked politics
before they're not a
would you agree they're not necessarily
a political brothers where they're going
out there saying stuff about politics
but yesterday he puts out this tweet can
you put that up there he says uh
biden's accomplishments highest gas
prices
worst inflation plummeting crypto prices
highest rent prices ever created new
incomprehensible language which we don't
many people don't speak if you're
reading this and voted for biden and you
still regret it and you still don't
regret it then you are the american
problem that could literally be a gatsat
tweet yeah that's
oh that's true the thing i'm already a
fan of this guy well we just introduced
you to this guy named jake paul jake
paul so jake meet cat got me jake
what do you think about what he said to
taylor what tyler what do you think
about it
i mean i i i mean obviously it hurts
your feelings you don't like this kind
of stuff but i think it's interesting
that you're seeing such a
revolt against joe biden specifically
from the influencer community like there
were a few rappers that came out in 2020
that were wearing mega hats you're
seeing the paul brothers come out like
you're seeing or at least jake paul
rather you're seeing this pushback on
the
far left the progressives against their
policies and your ideologies and and two
your point about the academy i mean
that's why it's so important that jake
paul does this or gad said or you or joe
rogan that we're doing what we're doing
because yes the academy is is great
right that's a wonderful idea but we
have to have a full-blown cultural
revolution i mean like like full on like
we had in the 60s because even if
even if donald trump wins the election
or jordan peterson wins uh pm in canada
it doesn't make a difference because the
tentacles are are so far wrapped around
the institutions that it doesn't matter
what you do uh think about uh uh lisa
page uh carter page and lisa strucker
whoever it was the fbi agents that were
going actively campaigning against
donald trump i mean it's the fbi the doj
hhs everybody it doesn't matter and so
donald trump wins what's he gonna do
he's gonna rule by executive order and
be a tyrant i mean that doesn't work so
i think it's wonderful to see this and
it's wonderful to see the younger
generation or at least some of them
start to wake up and realize what's
going on because yeah the
teaching a select group of people how to
be leaders is great in theory and it's
probably what we need but more so than
that we need a real
real cultural revolution you know i feel
i feel that way about guns
i feel that way about guns you know how
they're saying there's been 246 mass
shootings this year so far by the way
there was another one potentially
yesterday god got you heard about that
right what happened yesterday in texas i
did not know about this a guy walked
into maybe this morning or yesterday but
the guy walks into a
uh school class with a gun and they got
him oh the school resource officer shot
yeah yeah the school resource officer
shot them so with all these mass
shootings at their time i yesterday were
talking with you and michael francis
and the conversation was about well you
know what about the idea that matthew
mcconaughey pitched right raise the age
automatic background check you know and
certain weapons you can't have and you
know how many magazines you can all
anyways all these things that they're
pitching
and at the end i said okay even if we do
that and you move that in
that only prevents five percent to ten
percent of the mass shootings that
doesn't prevent the majority mass
shooting so uh tyler can you mute the so
so even if you do that you're you're
getting still the issue is not gonna go
away it needs to be more of a long-term
cultural change
where you know every other channel is
turning these guys into heroes where all
of a sudden the next person wants to
rise up and do it again so i think it's
more values and principles to your point
i think it's more values and principles
and but for a guy like jake paul to make
that comment for jake to tweet that out
it makes no sense i can't see jake
saying something like that but for him
to say he's got a lot of young followers
that follow him i mean look at that how
many likes did he get 156 000 uh likes
that he got that means 156 and by the
way it is the it is his most liked tweet
ever i believe on the amount of likes
that he gets and
most of his followers are younger people
to agree with that this is a guy that's
got 20 look at his youtube channel how
many subscribers he's got wow
yeah that's this guy okay that he made a
comment like that 20.4 million
subscribers
so i agree with you that long term but i
also think the academy part uh is more a
longer term thing where like even sixer
societies
what secret society still exists today
i would argue that what secret societies
what secret society still exists today
they have the power that they once had
what the world economic forum young
leaders foundation you say that's a
secret society oh that i mean they
produced uh justin trudeau came out of
there um there's a ton of political
leaders that have come out of the cloud
is that a secret though
i mean it's not like it's what what do
you mean by secret i mean there's only
fifty
secrets but it's not a secret freemason
how many presidents were former
freemason what's the number they talk
about 13 or 14 right
skull and bones secret society that's
from yale right that's from yale you got
it the illuminati is more like a
hollywood thing or you know what you
know the whole thing that they do
it doesn't exist does not exist whatever
but there are certain secret societies
but the outcome here is to develop
leaders
those are the presidents look at this
freemason presidents wow people that
were masonic presidents of the united
states what's the number washington
jefferson madison monroe uh it's 15.
polk buchanan johnson garfield mcgowan
fdr is a part of it uh
teddy roosevelt taft fdr and truman
what's the distribution of republicans
and democrats in that list
well none of them because there's zero
republicans there because the first
republican was lincoln yeah so these are
all federer you know these are all like
original original uh type of uh
uh uh well fdr is not yeah yeah
and then who's on the bottom right
that's guys truman truman truman
democrat
fdr democrat so there we go but again
you know to can you pull back up the
jake paul tweet
i got some feelings on that go forward
share your thoughts well
what you're gonna say something no no go
ahead well look
uh i'm gonna remove the person from the
statement because the person is an
absolute troll
clown some might call him some may call
him one of the most hated men in america
but he does get eyeballs so i'm gonna
remove
the troll clown this part this is the
mma exactly well no the
boxer youtuber influencer yeah troll
clown you would agree he's an all-time
troll
international he's a great troll right
he's a great troll he knows how to get
under people's skin and i'm not even
saying troll in a bad way he serves the
he's a positive okay absolutely but as
someone who has voted for biden he's
basically
saying hey buddy what does he say
if you've read this you're votive and
you still don't regret it then you're
then you're part of the american that
you're part of the american problem
here's what i will say
um
i'm not fixated on
i'm a democrat and that's it i'm going
to stand behind my men no at some point
and this is for everyone left right
middle center blue yellow red green
whatever at some point you have to be
like
[ __ ] maybe i was wrong
i don't know maybe i thought he was
going to do a better job than he is
i don't like this i had a conversation
with my mom last night and i was like
sewing notes and my mom
i was like mom how much do gas prices
need to go up or for you to like
for you to vote for trump i would never
i think he's disgusting what a horrible
human i go but mom look at my mom does
not have a lot of money you know
uh i go well you know five bucks
yeah i'd still vote 10 bucks well that's
a crap 20 bucks and she's like well i
don't like you know so you can see kind
of her wrestling with her mind
but
this is why i'm
full-on independent at this point i mean
thank you pbd podcast thank you
valuetainment for basically saying all
right adam you're no longer a
quote-unquote democrat i think it's and
by the way i don't identify as a
republican either i don't think a lot of
the things that trump has done or even
the mcconnells of the world have done
are exactly something i can get behind
but i think this is the advantage of
just being independent open-minded
because at some point a lot of people
who voted for trump no matter what he
did i could sit there and shoot someone
on fifth avenue and i'd still wouldn't
lose a vote well that's a [ __ ]
problem
if you're just gonna vote for somebody
who shoots somebody on fifth avenue
that's my guy
at the same time jake paul does have a
point here at at what point when there's
a recession and gas prices inflation do
you do you have to question what you've
always thought so can i can i come in
with some hardcore science here sure uh
so as someone who studies uh psychology
of decision making one of the things
that we study is what's called the
anchoring and adjustment problem when
you anchor yourself in a position
correct what does it take for me to be
able to move you away from that position
i assume that's very hard to do it's
very very very hard to do and so this
not not to engage in shameless plugging
but in chapter seven of the parasitic
mind i offer a methodology
for precisely doing that can i share it
with you guys please
so in chapter seven i talk about how to
seek truth right
and part of seeking truth is that when
incoming evidence comes in that is
contrary to your position you should
have the epistemic humility to to change
your opinion most people do not have
that people don't have that so here's
what i propose there's something called
nomological networks of cumulative
evidence now it's a big mouthful so let
me break it down for you let's suppose i
wanted to prove to you that
toy preferences are not socially
constructed right most social scientists
think that the reason why we have the
gender roles that we do is because your
parents are sexist pigs they teach
little johnny to play with the truck
they teach little linda to play with the
barbie doll and that starts a cascade of
gender role specialization okay i want
to prove to you that no
sex specific toy preferences are rooted
in our biology are rooted in our
evolutionary history how would i go
about altering your position so very
much like jake paul is saying what does
it take for you to alter your position
on by then
i'm saying how could i convince you of
my position and so so it's a very very
powerful methodology so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to find as much
data sources as much lines of evidence
distinct lines of evidence that will
hopefully sway you away from your
position let me give you examples sure
so i can get you data from developmental
psychology where children are too young
to have been socialized and i can show
you that those children already exhibit
those sex specific toy preferences in
other words they can't verbalize why
they like this but they will they will
go towards the truck or the doll so that
already negates the possibility that
it's due to socialization because
they're too young to have been
socialized so that's that's box one i
can get you data from verve monkeys and
rhesus monkeys and chimpanzees other
species where their infants also exhibit
the same-sex specific toy preferences as
human infants that's the second box
i can get you data from sub-saharan
africa different societies not western
societies and i can show you that their
children exhibit the exact same toy
preferences i'll just do one or two more
although the network is much bigger i
can get you data from 2 500 years ago
from ancient greece where on funerary
monuments the children are depicted
playing with exactly the same toys as we
see today and then one final kicker i
can get you data from pediatric
endocrinology whereby little girls who
suffer from congenital adrenal
hyperplasia it's a disorder that
masculinizes their behavior little girls
who have that disorder will have toy
preferences akin to those of little boys
so look what i've done bit by bit i have
put the epistemological noose around
your neck because i'm giving you data
from across cultures across
time periods
across species across disciplines all of
which triangulate to my position now
you'd like to think that someone is
honest enough that if they see all that
tsunami of evidence they will then be
swayed but here's the bad news even with
that much evidence most people put their
hands in their ears and go la la la i
don't want to hear it anchoring
anchoring so that so so what jake paul
notwithstanding that you guys are saying
he's a troll and so on he's actually
you know he's actually espousing a very
deep point which is our the architecture
of our human mind is not structured to
change our position we are built not to
seek truth but to win arguments and
therefore i don't want to hear about
your contrary evidence i'm sticking to
my this is why people want to live in
echo chambers and only just listen to
news that they agree with exactly but
the good news based on the size
scientific breakdown i'm full on mag at
this point thank you for that i
appreciate that but what you just said
adam good for you for
sharing uh where you're at and what jake
is saying for you to say okay cool
here's kind of what i'm seeing and the
conversation had with your mom yesterday
and you said you know what happens here
this is this is where what i've said and
i've been saying this for a while after
conversation tom ellsworth and i had
is the middle runs america period yeah
okay you don't need to win the left you
don't need to win the right you need to
win the middle yeah if the middle sides
with you
you're gonna win the election right so
for example if the middle is 12
if 80 to 12 is going to vote for you
you're winning right not not republican
not not democrat if 80 the middle votes
for you you're going to win the election
so
whoever's going to win the next like
they asked aoc i don't know if you saw
that when they asked aoc and she didn't
want to answer the questions like hey so
what do you think about uh uh tyler do
you have that story here as well
again yeah hey do you think if biden ran
again or she equivocated yeah she's like
well listen now the only thing you said
page number four bottom of four bottom
of four okay so you know hey if biden
ran would you support biden and she's
like
uh uh uh well
you know what we first need to do is uh
ocasio-cortez won't commit to back in
biden in 2024 we'll cross that bridge
when we get to it cnn i think if the
president has a vision then that's
something certainly we're willing to
entertain and examine when the time
comes a democrat who wields significant
amount of influence over the party's
progressive wing told cnn dana bash on
state union when asked if she plans to
support biden in 2024 election
and that's not a yes i said to which the
congresswoman replied we should endorse
when we get to it but i believe that the
president's been doing a very good job
so far and you know
should he run again i think that i you
know i think we'll take a look at it but
right now we need to focus on winning
the majority instead of presidential
election so in other words that's a
professional way of avoiding the
answering to questions so that that
that's what happens when you're in that
business for a while but
people on both sides are sitting there
saying this guy is the least popular
president we've ever had with polls so
you know if you're going to use poles
when you're winning you also ought to
use poles when you're losing and it's
not in a good situation so i think the
middle's running america right now and
if there is a party that's recruiting
the most people today if there is a
party that's recruiting most people
today i think it's the middle i don't
think it's the left i don't think it's
the right i think it's the middle can i
bring in some more psychology sure
so i feel like i should pay you for this
i'm getting a whole full-on mental
breakdown right here so i want you to
imagine this as the cork of a wine
bottle okay i i've i've explained this
previously but it's worth repeating so
there's an expression in arabic arabic
is my mother tongue so there's an
expression in arabic that basically says
getting drunk simply by smelling the
cork of the wine bottle which basically
refers to when someone doesn't is so
weak of in his constituency that they
don't need to actually drink the wine to
get drunk they simply whiff it and
they're already drunk now how do we
apply this to psychological processes
so look now i'm gonna drink from the
obama cork right oh my god he is so tall
and lanky and he has a mellifluous voice
and he speaks with the cadence of a
baptist minister now every single
syllable that he utters is pure empty
vacuous [ __ ] but my god
i'm getting drunk by the obama cork
right on the other hand i'm gonna now
smell the cork of trump
he's disgusting he's an ogre right
he he he speaks like a brash
brawler from the bronx right in both of
those cases when i got drunk i never
said anything of substance i didn't say
i like obama because of his fiscal
policy i hate trump because of his
immigration policy what i'm using are
peripheral cues meaning cues that don't
really matter to to to base my decision
on right one is uh presidential looking
and acting the other one is brash and
ogre
that's the problem with
the psychology of voters and that is
that instead of activating their
cognitive system here are the seven
reasons the substantive reasons why i
love biden or trump most of the populist
doesn't do that they base peripheral
cues and that's why we end up with
people voting for biden even though on
every single position they might prefer
trump i know a lot of my colleagues who
when i when i challenge them on why do
you vote for trudeau or right they could
never enunciate a position he looked
young he looked youthful he looked
he was handsome he had a young family
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] right none of
these reasons should be valid reasons
for why you should vote for him but yet
that's why we what happens we get
intoxicated by smelling the core so but
you're giving the personality versus
policy debate exactly right but a lot of
people do vote based on personality
exactly
so it's not based on policy you're
saying right right
isn't that sad right i mean i don't
think a lot of people are smart enough
to
break down policy by policy and that's
not a knock on the american voter i
think most people just vote with their
pocketbook you know as james carville
said we brought up yesterday it's the
economy stupid clearly people are not
happy with the economy right now
but a lot of times people will just look
on screen and just say yeah i like that
guy exactly or no i don't like the way
they talk
i'm into it or i'm not into that what's
more important that or winning the
middle
is it that or winning the middle because
i think the average voter does that
but the middle voter is sitting there
the independent voter the guy's in the
middle the the independent the
libertarian those guys are sitting there
saying
they have
okay so the pendulum of being able to
reason okay
whoever can reason the most
leads the country okay the complainers
are the complainers are the loudest so
they seem to be the biggest party
the and the complainers tend to recruit
a lot of the people that are kind of oh
that's what oh my god so that's what's
going on okay so the complainers recruit
the naive but the complainers cannot
recruit the the reasonable people that
know how to reason the people that are
in the middle that are able to reason
and they eventually have enough of a
voice you sit there and you say
huh
okay this guy makes sense
yeah i agree with them you know what
yeah that's what i'm gonna vote for
rogan okay again goes back to bill maher
conversation we had briefly yesterday i
think the currency again this you're
going to hear me saying this a lot
i think the currency of reasoning
is becoming very valuable today not
sensationalism not crying complaining
all of that stuff crying complaining has
been a very hot commodity the last 10 20
years especially the last two three four
five years right but you're gonna see
the ability to reason become valuable
again this sounds weird for where people
should say well this should this should
have been valuable for a long time no
when social media came out complainers
got a hot mic
and complainers got a chance to go out
there and blow up and complainers became
celebrities aoc is a queen of
complainers and look what happened to
her that was a hot commodity right she
threw a lot of complaining she got a lot
of eyeballs and she got people to say
yeah that's exactly right that's and
then people are like uh you just cost
new york city 25 000 jobs at 150 000 a
year salary
amazon and amazon went elsewhere so
you're complaining just cost us 25 000
good jobs yes but if amazon would have
came your rent would have gone up of
course
do you want those 150 000 out of your
jobs no they should go elsewhere other
cities are like dude amazon we will
gladly take you buddy they had a bidding
bring those jobs to us we'll take it so
so it's becoming sexy again to reason
those who can reason people are finding
it very very attractive and that's
generally the people in the middle well
and i i think if if i can speak about
you know the platform that guys like
jordan and i have been able to build i
mean i could have never imagined that 10
15 years ago i could ever have the type
of platform that would have been
reserved for you know rock stars and
actors and so on right so i think to
your point i think there is in the
middle the the silent majority are
starving for commonsensical people who
come and actually say exactly what
they're thinking this is why by the way
notwithstanding what you're talking
about the academy i i agree with having
those programs if we can just instill
the courage and the silent majority to
speak out already the battle will be won
this is why i talk about activate your
inner honey badger right because i
receive a million emails every week from
people who say i'm on your side and
they're corrections officers and their
truck drivers and their fancy professors
but for whatever reason they have this
impediment whereby they're scared to
speak their mind
they actually overestimate the risk i
understand that you could be canceled
you could
estimate the risk not underestimate so
they think
it's going to be worse than it's
actually going to be exactly so for
example the the the administrators at
the university who are beholden to the
the few loud activists why are you
always acquiescing to them like what why
is it that you are always catering your
policies to the 10 people who are the
most committed or the corporations too
right exactly the corporations do the
same thing they think as though you know
disney is going to completely you know
fall apart if we don't have ultra work
stuff so you overestimate the risks from
the woke when in reality look i'm still
standing
i don't want to jinx it but i'm
apparently i'm uncancelable i i truly am
the like the teflon king well i don't
think it's because there's a magic
recipe it's simply because i don't care
i'm not so afraid of it now you might
come along and say oh but that's because
you're tenured therefore you're not
afraid to lose your job but listen when
i get a million death threats where i
have to walk in on campus with security
tenure didn't protect me there right so
when i almost got an anxiety attack
because i don't know who's going to come
at me we had to file a police report
with the montreal police at my
university because of the number of
death threats but i walk around like a
honey badger i'm not trying to tooth my
horn but
look it's better to live five minutes
with integrity than 500 years as a
coward right and so a lot of people
who's that william wallace
is that true i don't know that sounds
like i just came up with it from top of
my head but
i guess many people have had similar but
the honey badger takes what he wants
honey badger does i mean for those of
you who don't know who are listening to
the show the honey badger has been
ranked as the fiercest animal in the
world it's the size of a small dog and
yet it could withstand the attack of six
adult lines the reason why i say six is
because you could probably go on on
youtube now and see the the
videos right where there are literally
six adult lions that are intimidated by
this one honey badger why because it's
fierce so be ideologically fierce if
you've got a position that you think is
worthwhile you know standing on don't
cower away don't be a little punk there
you go there you go yeah this guy's a
badass can i ask you a question and this
goes to pat's point of the middle runs
america
um
and i guess
my question is um is america bipolar
because every eight years every four to
eight years
the pendulum swings left to right
republican to democrat when's the last
time we've had consecutive democrats in
office or consecutive republicans in
office
to pat's point in 2016.
you know hillary didn't campaign in the
midwest she took it for granted trump
came in he was all over michigan all
over ohio all over iowa boom shocker
alert he won the election
2020
the blue wall held what as they say and
biden won the election but every four to
eight years
the pendulum swings i think it's because
hope springs eternal right someone else
said this so basically at any given
point after a certain number of years
that someone is in power and my
pocketbook is not doing well or whatever
it is that i'm upset about then the only
thing that triggers in my head why don't
i switch now and go with the other folks
maybe they have but that's change change
change the change right change agent
right so
you know one of the things that i found
out in studying decision making for 30
years is that we are far from being sort
of the hyper rational creatures that we
are otherwise
made out to be by classical economists
right classical economists have this
view called homo economicus homo
economicus means ultra rational you
apply these decision making procedures
you maximize utility whereas in reality
when you study human decision making
we're ultra non-rational enough right we
choose someone based on their height as
a politician well what does your height
have to do with your policies but you
simply look more presidential if you are
tall we haven't had a president under
like six foot and forever well by the
way whenever someone tells me hey why
don't you run for primer so i said sorry
i'm too short
it doesn't matter what what's in here it
the fact that i'm i i don't clock in at
six feet i'm out but it is a thing it is
a thing because people use these
peripheral candles if i'm tall that
means i'm dominant i'm to be trusted
right by the way ceos of companies are
taller than average right so the
napoleon bonaparte who was 5'4 is a very
rare phenomenon most elected people
whether it be as a ceo or as a president
are tall well what's the story with
nixon and jfk and that debate if you
listened on radio back in 64 whatever it
was 61
if you listened on radio you thought
nixon won the debate exactly but if you
watched on tv because i think it was the
first televised debate right pat
jfk won the debate because he was more
polished he looked better
uh nixon was a little more like
disheveled kind of bearded five o'clock
shadow
um so
attractiveness does matter
yeah exactly right so then that that
means joe biden is sexy as hell
he's he's hotter than leo and well he's
hotter than the orange man i guess
that's that's in the orange man yeah
somebody just commented saying whether
you vote rockefeller red or rockefeller
blue uh in a new world order the joke's
on you right i mean i i don't know what
that really obviously we know what the
guy is trying to insinuate but
and he rhymed too congratulations yeah
smedley butler good for you man total
rapper uh but
you know
you're saying all this stuff about where
it's at and what's happening but again
for me my confidence and peace of mind
of the future being bright is this new
movement of people who are able to
reason because if we go through the
sequencing on how i believe it happens
first there's a complainer
when there's a complainer the guy that
has the ability to reason he's got
better things to do than to argue with
the complainer okay
so then the complainer all of a sudden
creates momentum
and he recruits eight people 22 people
79 people 328 people now he's got 1200
people
then the guy who's got the ability to
reason sitting there saying dude this
guy is creating some momentum
then the complainer starts converting
some of the people that the guy
who's has the ability to reason thought
they used to be reasonable okay then he
says i gotta now get involved then the
guy that has the ability to reason and
he's got a backbone gets involved and
start talkings and reasons through all
these issues then those people say yeah
i forgot i'm a guy that leans more
towards a reasonable side this
complainer you don't know what you're
talking about i flip
i think there's a big awakening of
people that can reason today and that's
what's happening and it's exciting
because most people that have the
ability to reason
and and they're driven by logic and they
can have an argument and kind of go
through and listen to both sides they're
typically so busy living their lives
they have no tolerance or time to go and
fight every single battle complainers
want to fight every battle those who
want to reason they don't have that kind
of pat what do you think is it
talked about anchoring nope this is how
i believe i'm i'm doubling down on my
position you're talking about being
reasonable what are the key elements in
being reasonable so you have to hear
both sides you have to hear the
motivations on both sides
the whys of both sides the stories of
both sides and then like for example
like right now for me okay i'm trying to
identify who's going to be the next ceo
of one of the companies you know two
three four five years from now whatever
timeline it's okay so i have to go
through everybody and i have to process
everybody and have to see the situation
what everybody else is in that guy's
motivation is this this guy's motivation
is that he's got a shorter lifespan that
one's a little bit scared this one's
fully capable just doesn't want the
responsibility that one wants the
responsibility and wants the job but
he's not capable this so you have to
enter that guy needs a little bit more
to that guy's more about his uh you're
looking at everything and then you sit
there and you say okay
i think this is the best candidate
you're what you're describing is
literally one of my lectures in my
psychology decision making class what
are the types of decision rules that
people use when they're making decisions
in multi-attribute choices you just
describe many ultra attributes
motivation
lifespan and so on right so typically
you could do one of two things you could
either look at all of the attributes
weighted by their importance right so
for example if i'm choosing between
different cars if gas efficiency is a
more important attribute to me than
price then i will weigh it differently
i'll put it all together and i'll pick
the card that scores the highest on all
of those attributes but oftentimes
people don't do what you just said pat
what they do is what's called the
lexicographic rule lexicographic rule
means
i only look at my most important
attribute and i choose the alternative
that scores highest on that attribute so
for example if i were choosing between
toothpaste and price is the most
important attribute i'll pick the
toothpaste that has the cheapest price
and that's it so all the other 10
attributes i never looked at that's what
i used by the way as a psychological
mechanism to explain why a lot of people
voted for trump right because even if
hillary clinton when you put all of the
attribute together might have scored
higher than trump many of the population
only looked at a singular attribute
let's suppose i'm an immigration guy i
only care about immigration and if
rightly or wrongly i think that trump
scores better on immigration than
hillary i stop right there i choose
trump i was using that to explain the
psychological mechanisms for why trump
won to sam harris sam harris is a guy
who went completely trump derangement
syndrome right i mean every single
person who voted for trump must have
been a nazi and i said that's what sam
harris said i mean
no i'm not saying said but that's the
position he was sort of advocating uh
sam harris you you tell him any
phenomenon he'll link it to trump you
just got diabetes he's going to explain
to you and by the way he's super
brilliant is it the same sam harris who
debated
and actually it's funny because i've
i've always loved sam i
appreciate him he he's supposed to be a
rational guy a meditation but he's got
trump derangement he's got such trump
deranged syndrome by the way so does 50
of america exactly right
except that they don't pretend that they
are the hyper-rational guys that sam
harris is but but but trump truly did
break sam's brain and so i used that
explanation to to
to to at least offer him a possible way
to understand why people who are not
nazis and who sleep with their sisters
could have voted for trump right if i
prefer as i said immigration and that's
the only attribute i look at
it will be perfectly rational for me to
choose trump over hillary i don't have
to be a nazi who sleeps with my sister
and so decision making is really an
incredible field because it allows us to
understand the cognitive processes that
people go through in making a decision
how do i choose a mutual fund how do i
choose a politician how do i choose a
mate so this is pretty much what i've
done in my academic career study
psychology and decision making so you
really are in my wheelhouse here i i
will tell you you know for uh for for me
years ago when you're going through the
conversation about you know when you're
younger all you want to think about
what's the key to success what's the key
to success hard work choosing the right
spots doing this doing that doing this
from everybody i've uh
watched win in business or they did very
well in life
the best ones were those who were better
at making decisions and processing
issues so i always wanted to talk to a
person and then ask them how did you
come to this conclusion
because that process of how you came to
this if they're willing to tell you the
real truth because sometimes people will
just give you the lazy answer i don't
want the lazy answer give me the real
answer
how did you come to this conclusion and
if they give you the real
methodology of how kim that they came to
that conclusion you just figured out a
formula
got it so first there was that
experience with your dad that you
watched and i left the mark okay so
that's deep that's emotional that's
painful got it then
you notice that maybe you were yourself
wrong but that happened to you when
somebody treated you and judge you the
way you judge your dad and you realize
you didn't like it he said your dad must
have not liked it as well because that's
got it three you were hanging on to
something that your dad did years ago to
your mom
and that's between them where you took
it personally to you he never did it to
you he did it to your mom but you love
your mom
fair okay get it but that doesn't mean
he did it god so you were able to let
that go how did you let that go through
an experience you had spiritual you had
rock bottom
a girl broke your heart you lost
somebody in your life so did you need to
go through that to make that decision
yes no who knows and then eventually so
there's a certain somebody just went
there yeah so was that autobiography i
was going to say he just went boom boom
boom no no but but
but but we don't talk like that right
but we decide like that so if we're able
to call a timeout and say got it here's
what we're doing with this part this
totally makes sense here's what we're
going to do next like when we wanted to
move from la to cali from california to
texas okay right i sat in a room and i'm
looking at everybody
i got merle who's about to get married i
got her husband certified system i got a
shout out yeah totally i get all these
guys sitting in front of me i'm like
okay how am i going to sell texas to
these guys all right so i start with an
open-ended question i'll never forget
this meeting was in 2011.
okay and i say so guys what do you think
about texas texas
oh man i've heard such bad things about
texas really tell me what you've heard
did you know that texas this is today
now they start saying about the texas
stuff man i could never go to work in
cowboy uniform like you know you have to
wear these belts i see you think people
in texas wear buckles yeah i mean that's
a dude horn with the belt like you think
on the freeway you know hey
so then eventually gradually i took all
the concerns and i brought back stories
to address every concern and i did it
over and over and over again and then i
had to sell jen jen didn't want to move
i had to sell melvin melvin didn't want
to move i had to sell family i had to
sell him plot salary and eventually like
guys
uh we have a meeting with governor perry
and mara frisco mayor maso
and we're going to go meet with nolan
ryan and we're going to meet with don
nelson and we're going to make a
decision whether we like texas or not
but look we may not like it let's just
see what it's like then we go to texas
we spend a whole day with them
then on the flight back i'm like so
what'd you guys think about texas
well you know it's just more impressive
than i thought
okay and then two months later guys
we're moving to texas so it sounds like
they weren't anchored on their uh it
took four years to move everybody so why
did you move from texas to here
while i moved from texas to here yeah
you you so you went to california to
texas than to here yeah you remember how
hard i was fighting to stay in texas
remember what you had to listen walk me
through those list of issues
in love with addison adam used to live
in this community called addison and he
was just
yeah he was jason jason yard house jason
from yard house but born and raised in
miami i did not want to come back this
is a very good question though because
there this argument of texas to here is
a different story so to me
texas on a golf score is probably
the best place to live on a golf score
raising kids
career
job
travel
airport taxes
regulation balance
left alone mixture you got every
national possibility cost of living
in every way it's again i would
specifically put dallas at the top and i
would probably put you know dallas
houston austin pick and choose okay san
antonio barclay's not a fan of san
antonio for different reasons but we're
not going to get back today the
basketball player
san antonio women are pretty yeah it's
easy
that's crazy so but you got all these
markets that you're looking at so for us
it got to a point where we kept coming
to florida
for uh a breakers hotel which i love
breakers hotel we've got if you've
stayed there before or not it's
beautiful i spent all day yesterday at
palm beach beautiful i love breakers i
love palm beach and then we started one
day accidentally we're sitting outside
i'm having a cigar and it's like
midnight jen and i are having a glass of
wine right outside of breakers and i
said babe
um
this reminds me of bandar palavi in iran
when my grandparents had a place there
and it was by the water was humid
it was bipolar weather one minute it's
raining next minute it's so emotionally
i got connected i love the water i'm a
water guy
and lifestyle wise i love the lifestyle
here and i said for 20 years i've been
going 80 hours a week i want to still go
80 hours a week but i want to do 80
hours a week by the water yeah and so we
kept everything there and we moved the
media company here because i felt it'd
be a lot easier recruiting talent from
new york or dc or baltimore
to south florida than it would be to
recruit people to dallas i don't think
we can build a media company out of
dallas based on the people that we
wanted to recruit so that's how the
decision making you know it's very
instructive the decision making that
you've been going through because i just
came back from
austin
where i i gave two talks at ut austin
and they might be interested in in
extending an offer and then i met the
people from university of austin i don't
know if have you guys heard of that new
university barry weiss's university very
well i i don't know if that's the right
name but yeah she's involved with it so
it's a new university that's uh trying
to sort of position itself as a
classical liberal school anti-woke you
know critical thinking
and so i met the president of that
university and so my wife and i are
exactly facing that decision if we
decide to eventually leave montreal as
texas better or as florida but i guess
your final consulting advice would be
come to florida well
here's here's uh the other part with
florida versus uh
texas
uh the left has really targeted texas
the last 20 years yeah they've moved
people to texas to convert texas and
they're winning turn it from red to
purple to blue you got it right right
now texas is probably
it used to be florida being a purple
state right now it's probably more texas
being a purple state right okay if it
isn't already there it's on its way to
being there
uh uh florida just flipped red they got
two more on the right so now it's more
of a red state than a purple state adam
doesn't like that but it is now a red
state
uh uh florida the governor is young so
if your run rate is you assume this
guy's gonna run some say he's gonna run
i don't think he's gonna run against
trump i don't think it's a good idea but
let's just say he runs if he runs uh you
know would one of his guys replace and
take florida as a governor who knows if
he stays for six years
and he's done a good job the state's
probably going to want another guy like
him to run so let's say that protects
you for another 10 years right so the
next time a leftist type of a person
takes office to be a governor is
probably going to be
10 years from now which is 2032. between
now and 2032 you have enough run rate to
do whatever you want to do and build up
for yourself so
uh i think life's and i think austin i
don't know if you've been to austin with
the homelessness yeah it's not a good
situation when it comes down to the
homelessness
and austin's probably also the most
wokest city in all of texas yeah i know
a lot of people love austin i know musk
is there in a row you know a lot of
people are there but i think uh i think
austin's gonna be the
uh uh stepping stone to end up in
florida i think it's like a pit stop for
a lot of people i think it's gonna be
two three four five years
and the next thing you know people are
going to say well i think i'm moving to
florida so you don't regret your
decision let me tell you why else
because
what what is a very big influence in
where you live is a community that
gravitates to a place like armenians
moved to glendale california right okay
so guess where we moved to glendale
california assyrians are in torlak if
you live in turlock modesto you know a
lot of assyrians if you're in
detroit there's a lot of assyrians you
can say where the irish move to you can
say where italians live you know new
york certain parts where dominicans live
where mexicans live salvadorians live
puerto ricans live
uh
the the young i look at the youngest
movement that's taking place that are
for the most part independent thinkers
that think for themselves and they can
reason that's the crypto community the
crypto community are filled with they
think for themselves okay this doesn't
mean they're left or right but they will
think for themselves they don't like
control they don't like authority they
don't like people tell them what to do
they want to be left alone they don't
know they don't like centralized they
want decentralized
that's the mindset of somebody that can
think for themselves right the crypto
capital of the world is becoming miami
if the crypto capital of the world is
becoming miami those types of thinkers
are moving to miami okay so then if you
think about you wanting to move to south
florida then you have to go based on age
the younger you are the more south you
are if you want to be around people that
are older the more north you are so if
you want to if you're in your 70s and 80
move to vero beach if you're in your 40s
fort lauderdale's good if you're in your
40s acting like you're in your 20s you
may want to live in miami hey
do you know anybody like that guys
i don't know
guys so that's that's the processing
when it comes down to florida thank you
for that uh and your tan which is on
point right like
you're gonna like that a lot better here
in south florida than in canada my wife
looked at me she goes how the hell do
you get so dark so quickly literally we
just we're just walking around you're
like a middle eastern hello what are you
talking about exactly right exactly
right you have the same problem you have
but if you but if you talk to nikki
freed
nikki fried would say a lot of people in
florida are not happy with florida
did you see what happened
she's running for governor of florida oh
yeah okay she was she was she was kind
enough to come and be on the podcast
last saturday
not last saturday this saturday or last
saturday like eight days ago or
something like that and then we had a
diabeela here which jedidiah just
launched her show jedidiah bella live
she didn't end up she's now doing her
show three times a week she's from fox
right she's from fox and she was on the
view oh right now she's here with us she
just moved here a couple months ago and
we're hosting her podcast and she's
crushing it she's absolutely she's an
absolute beast you you're going to see
that that the show blow up with what
she's got going on
her and nikki had a exchange if you've
not seen it you have to see it by the
way do we put the exchange of them 2 on
youtube for
just to put jedediah villa versus nicki
free have we put that together or not
there's a few of them okay yeah because
i thought that exchange was so powerful
them going back and forth so by the way
i nikki freed some of her policy
positions and her talking points i don't
exactly agree with but i got to give her
kudos for coming on holding her own she
she's welcome here anytime she wants to
come back she's welcome here anytime
have you ever had a guest that you were
incredibly excited to have hence you
invited them but then once you don't
have to give names but then once they
came here they completely tanked and
you're you're positioned
without giving names there might be a
certain candidate yeah for president
that has been here so when i used to
when i used to do uh yeah i mean listen
joe jorgensen i will say the name
because now it's like people talk about
it not because in a bad way
but i wanted like i brought joe
jorgensen because i wanted to go deeper
in libertarian policies you know who
george organ
yeah yeah and she didn't want to do that
and when basic questions were ants asked
i didn't you know
push her too hard i asked her basic
questions who's the toughest debate
you've ever had
you know because a lot of times people
in your world they just talk a lot and
there's no pushback there's no debate
from from the world like the stanford
people that you're talking to
you're going to get pushed back because
if you're in the circle people are going
to push back oh you're wrong you're this
you're that and you'll banter with them
whether it's on twitter there's a part
of me that i think actually likes that
to have that banter i don't think she
has
been punched it's like the person that's
read all the books on boxing and has
watched all the fights but hasn't been
in too many well that's the concept of
anti-fragility right you need to be
exposed to stressors for your system
he's a beast by the way yeah he's a
beast have you done stuff with him or no
no anti-fr fragile uh of course yeah
he's a oh yeah he he's somebody that i
uh
i listen i had every single one of my
executives in the company read skin in
the game everybody yeah if folks if you
haven't read skin in a game even if it's
not a newer book it's like five six
years old whatever eight years old
highly recommend reading uh that book
you know one of the things that i can i
can put on my cv with pride it's sick
book is uh the author oh you've never
read that
oh buddy this is like
mandatory for anybody that wants to
become better at reasoning let me tell
you let me tell you a story about naseem
nasim basically hates 99 of humanity
right to him everybody is a fraud
everybody's a charlatan
now i'm lucky enough to have never made
it into that camp i've always been in
the you know psychologists are full of
[ __ ] this is nasim speaking except god
sad
all these academics are full of [ __ ]
except you know gatsat and so i've
always said as long as i've gotten a
seam on my side i think i'm doing the
right thing because this guy truly is a
i mean he's a honey badger maybe on
steroids in the sense that
he tends to go after people sometimes in
in a in a rough way where they they
don't necessarily deserve it i mean i
don't know if you agree with that he's a
fantastic guy he's a lovely guy he's a
very good friend we spoke on the phone
he's in lebanon now a couple of weeks
ago but he's lebanese as well he he's
also that this guy is
and he i mean he does not suffer fools
godly you know i mean he's got you he
goes off by the way you're a
self-identified honey badger trivia
question for the both of you yeah what
nfl pro bowler
heisman candidate
is nicknamed the honey badger oh no
famous name there's like the the
nickname give me a position what
position
plays defense defensive back yeah i like
the offensive i figured you would know
this this is like this guy's nickname
he's like a safety that's true
because my son actually point i don't
remember his name but he said daddy look
they're using your terms yeah exactly
what did he play for who did he play for
plays for kansas uh played for kansas
city for a long time it's you how do you
say it tyrone uh
is he a recent guy number three yeah
he's a famous guy 32. he almost won the
heisman he might have even won the
heisman i don't know
very famous who's this tyrone matthew
yeah number 32. okay provost check check
is it no yeah number three the honey
badger yeah yeah yeah that was his
nickname badass dude he's a beast by the
way anytime
brady talks so much trash to the they
went back and forth but this guy didn't
back down brady didn't back down
uh and by the way going back to joe
jorgensen i walked away
i walked away thinking to myself
are they prepping candidates
like are they doing the behind the
closed doors conversations like what is
the process for somebody to be the
candidate and then we have dave smith
here and i said how does the libertarian
party do you know how the libertarian
party chooses their vps no the candidate
doesn't the party does mm-hmm so did you
know this or no so
jones was explaining that that's like
john cohen spike jones you went to a
complete different this guy threw you
off by the way so no but but libertarian
party you don't pick your vp
you you run
and you run to become the vp so you run
not only to become the president the
nominee but you also run to become the
vp which means there is no synergy
between the two which i think that
system is broken because they got to get
along they got to be on the same page
very weird there's there's certain
changes that parties got to make there
are arguments a lot of them i fully
agree with
but uh joe jorgensen threw me off but
yeah i've had had a few other interviews
that i did where
i was like this is gonna be not that
good but it ended up being great those
are the ones that are very why do you
ask that question by the way oh just
because i'm you know i'm someone who
just lives life to its fullest and so
i'm always when i wake up and i have a
guest coming i'm always kind of gleeful
i'm excited i'm ready who was yours have
you had one or of the the one that
impressed me or the ones that happened
uh
negative yes i had a political scientist
from uh i think boston university that
was a total
as you know
inviting someone simply because they
have good credentials won't necessarily
lead to a good conversation they have to
also have the personality so if you
bring someone and you're pulling teeth
because they answer you very dry and
especially if you're doing it remotely
where you know it's yeah you you need i
need to get a fire out of you man and if
i can't get that it's going to die very
quickly and for us to maintain it for an
hour so i would say probably that guy
just because of his personality who is
better than expected meaning you're like
i'm excited for this but whoa bam that
turned out to be incredible well the
most powerful one was a gentleman
who spent 29 years
in prison for a murder that he didn't
commit
and i actually have him in the in the
last chapter of my next book that i'm
working on now recipe for the good life
i i use them as an example for how to
live without anger in your heart because
as we were chatting i said to him power
you know you you must be the new age
buddha
because if i were in your position
you're a much better man than i am
because if i were in your position i'd
want to be burning down the world right
because i would be so angry and venomous
and yet the guy was so gracious he had
such uh you know such such gratitude at
life and actually he said something very
powerful to me which i i discussed in
the book his his sister i think suffers
from cerebral palsy and she's bedridden
her whole life and so he i said well how
did you do it to stay so grounded he
said well look i see what my sister's
going through and yet she has a smile on
her face so i had no reason to be filled
with hate in my heart so a guy just
spent almost three decades in prison and
is acting with such incredible grace and
so i said i need to so far so i would
probably say of all the great gas i've
had that guy's life lesson is right up
there david mccallum by the way that's
his name
when i hear stories like that it's it's
heartbreaking and then how they can be
something positive about it all
but we did have a guest recently i won't
say the name where he was
what i would say non-committal what do
you thought yeah you could go either way
with it mm-hmm older gentlemen yeah i'm
talking about it and my mother we took
him out to dinner yeah and during dinner
i remember the day do you remember the
dinner yeah yeah so
you know you like food not really
i was so excited for him too i was like
i've been watching was he your guess he
was you nominated i've been following
that guy for every second i always by
the way
he's he's a qualified genius like he's
got well that's the problem right yeah
but i don't like friends sitters i
always say that the ones who equivocate
are never the ones who are interesting
to hang out with you want people who i
mean you want that if they're
opinionated they can back it up but the
ones who are always equivocating on the
fence they're very would you say that
this gentleman that we have in mind was
a fence sitter
yeah but but you know who i liked a lot
who called me a freaking [ __ ] on the
on the interview at the end do you know
who thomas jefferson's uh yeah is uh
what's the guy's name it's uh
uh he's got one of those lucian truscott
yes you ever seen this one no yeah i had
lucian truscott on and i asked him a
question i said so you want thomas
jefferson's statue to be replaced by
harriet tubman and you want it to be
removed to a different place i never
said remove i said but you wanted to go
to a different location or yes
i said what's your problem with thomas
jefferson he's it's his great great
great great grandfather
and i said so why why do you have such a
big problem with thomas jefferson he
just kept saying stuff saying stuff same
stuff find a clip real quick because
it's very entertaining it's right off
the bat you'll see it
anyways eventually i said
eventually i said so who's your favorite
president he didn't want to answer it
i said tell me who's your favorite
president
and he said uh barack obama click on it
he said barack obama i said and then go
to all the way to the end just take it
all the way to the end all the way to
the end all the way to the end all the
way a little bit back a little bit back
a little bit back
i've had a blast with you yeah
are one of my favorite interviews of all
time
yeah i wish you nothing but the best
okay
all good take care of yourself
goodbye bye-bye
it doesn't seem listen go back go back
go back go back oh [ __ ]
i wish you nothing but the best
okay
all good take care of yourself
goodbye bye-bye
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is all the notes i prefer
and i gotta tell you it's one of my top
10 favorite interviews of all time
do you know why though you know why
though because he actually has a
position yeah and he was pushing so hard
and he was he was not like he was
hardcore on his position
and uh we had banter and uh it was it
was exciting so
why were you an
[ __ ] because you were challenging him
on his position because because the only
people he interviews with is people that
agree with him agree with him and i was
surprised that he said yes because i
asked for him he said yes i said great
see this is the challenge when sometimes
a guy he's just a youtuber and they're
like oh [ __ ] i'm sitting down with you
yeah i'm saying with this guy
oh i wasn't ready for this well you
should have done a little research i had
no idea that i thought this was just
that's all good i'm kind of glad you
didn't do any research thank you for not
doing research because it allows us to
have a little more fun here's another
question for you do you think that given
your middle eastern background that you
you know uh take your foot off the the
pedal and are nicer to guess precisely
because of the hospitality culture
and before you answer i do that because
on twitter when i engage people i can be
quite irascible right if you start
pissing me off i'm gonna come after you
and your ancestors and your future
descendants right i can be combative
right but if you come on my show all
that goes away because you're now a
guest of mine yeah and and it's just
simply gauche for me to so people will
sometimes get upset at me and say why
didn't you destroy this guy i said well
but he was a guest i can't i there's a
code of conduct once you agree to be in
my home
and so i'm wondering if you have the
same kind of uh etiquette yes but but if
you're if you if it gets okay so for me
many times i've done interviews and i've
looked like a fool because i didn't know
the information and the other person's
but i'm learning yeah yeah so i'm not
doing this because i'm trying to teach
the world about what i know that my
expertise is business
i'm doing this because i'm going through
the process of learning and recreating
myself and have certain philosophies and
beliefs and i wanted to get stronger and
the only way that happens is by people
saying you're wrong you're gonna tell me
why
never thought about that before how
about this
and then we go into that mode where it
gets heated and there's a lot of banter
then
comes out good ideas so i enjoy those
and i'm respectful but i have no problem
pushing the envelope i mean you have to
realize i've sat with
sammy double garvano i mean this this
guy's not like a you know you're upset
with uh michael yes i've sat with the
mobsters i've sat with phil leonetti the
former underboss of the
philadelphia crime family i've sat with
you know
people that i've done 30 years jail time
i want to know like what the motive is
with certain things so uh very uh
respect no matter who the individual is
this doesn't mean you support what life
this person lived but it's purely
respect you want to learn and it's
worked out well but today listen it was
great having you on finally to meet you
what a pleasure guys truly
so much thank you so much for coming out
and i like that
sorry i like that yesterday we had a
descendant of the godfather on yesterday
with michael friend say shout out to him
and now we've got the actual godfather
honor
two thousand
different kind of godfather exactly
folks if you haven't read his book
please put the link below for people to
be able to go buy his book uh thursday
we're doing a podcast again stay tuned
for that we'll see you guys in two days
when is your podcast you're doing
thursday as well thursday afternoons and
is there anything you got something
going on with your dating sites
we'll see what's going on that sounds
good jedediah today 1pm jedediah today
1pm having said that brother thank you
so much for coming out thank you thank
you everybody bye bye bye bye bye ciao
that was good
you